[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición del
programa enlace cono Sur desde la ciudad
de Río de Janeiro en este nuevo episodio
hablaremos del desafío que supone la
gestión del agua en un país como Brasil
donde la mitad de las aguas residuales
no pasan por ningún tipo de tratamiento
en la Bahía de guanabara mi espalda
considerada el símbolo de la ciudad más
turística de Brasil cada segundo son
arrojados cerca de 18.000 litros de
aguas fecales
se trata de un problema Global en el
país más grande de América Latina unos
35 millones de personas no tienen acceso
al agua potable y alrededor de 100
millones viven en áreas donde la
recolección de las aguas sucias es
mínima o nula las autoridades sanitarias
destacan que la falta de un sistema
eficiente de alcantarillado puede
acarrear diversas enfermedades como
diarrea hepatitis e infecciones
parasitarias que eventualmente conllevan
la muerte de Los afectados Río de
Janeiro es la síntesis de la situación
nacional en ese estado brasileño donde
viven 17 millones de personas solo el
49% de las aguas residuales son tratadas
al menos 8 millones de personas viven en
áreas donde no hay alcantarillado y de
hecho cuatro de las 20 ciudades de
Brasil donde hay cero tratamiento de las
aguas sucias están aquí en Río de
Janeiro Sergio Ricardo es el fundador
del movimiento Bahía viva y lleva años
denunciando el estado de abandono de
este entorno natural y la mala calidad
del agua en Río de Janeiro Sergio como
resumir casi 30 años de desastre
medioambiental el inicio de este
programa de descontaminación se remonta
a 1995 el año pasado se cumplieron 30
años de la conferencia internacional de
medio ambiente la Eco 92 después tuvimos
los Juegos Olímpicos de 2016 gastaron
decenas de miles de millones de reales y
por increíble que parezca hasta hoy Los
troncos colectores que deberían
transportar las aguas residuales de la
residencias hacia estas grandes
estaciones de tratamiento un total de
seis estaciones que fueron construidas
por reformadas hasta hoy las aguas
sucias nos llegan para ser tratadas no
hay la menor duda de que hubo una gran
corrupción en el uso de los recursos que
fueron destinados a la descontaminación
de la Bahía de guanabara las aguas
fecales no son la única amenaza para
esta Bahía que posee una importante
biodiversidad y ofrece sustento a miles
de cada día al menos 98 toneladas de
basura son vertidas en este litoral algo
que no preocupa muchos cariocas que
parece no tener miedo de bañarse en esta
playa la playa de flamengo parece un
escenario idílico pero el INEA el
instituto estatal del medio ambiente la
declaró no apta para el baño debido a la
baja calidad del agua
yo frecuento esta playa desde que era
niño nunca me ha pasado nada estoy
seguro de que es una playa contaminada
pero yo asumo mis riesgos
el futuro de esta Bahía podría cambiar
gracias a la nueva ley de saneamiento
básico aprobada en 2020 esta Norma abrió
camino a la captación de la inversión
privada con el fin de universalizar el
tratamiento de las aguas residuales y el
abastecimiento de agua potable en el
país en abril de 2021 la empresa pública
de tratamiento del agua de Río de
Janeiro fue privatizada en noviembre de
2021 la empresa aguashio asumió el
saneamiento de los 27 municipios del
estado de Río de Janeiro esta compañía
promete realizar inversiones millonarias
para evitar que las aguas residuales sin
tratamiento lleguen a la Bahía de
guanabara Cabe destacar que hoy todos
los ríos de esa ciudad turística están
contaminados y desprenden un olor
nauseabundo incluso los que pasan por
lugares icónicos como el sambódromo o el
estadio del maracaná zimbalandria es
portavoz de la empresa aguas de Río sin
valen qué habéis recibido las
instalaciones de la empresa Pública del
Estado de Río de Janeiro
recibimos la mayoría de las
instalaciones en una situación muy
precaria muchas sin manutención algunos
tramos no estaban funcionando
principalmente las tuberías y
alcantarillado en general estaban
totalmente obstruidos
llevamos muchos años de escándalos de
corrupción de robo de obras frustradas
por qué deberíamos creer que esta vez va
a ser diferente y la Bahía va a ser
limpiada
este contrato tiene reglas y metas
claras que tienen que ser cumplidas
existe un sistema estricto de gestión y
de fiscalización en la presa privada en
esa primer año ya hicimos una serie de
intervenciones y una serie de cambios
que llevan a las personas a creer que
esta vez realmente tendremos un
funcionamiento diferente
de momento las plantas de tratamiento
operan al 34% de la capacidad prevista
la gran pregunta es si la privatización
del sistema de recolección y tratamiento
de las aguas sucias es de por sí una
solución
la perspectiva de recuperación de la
Bahía guanabara existe técnicamente es
posible sin embargo además de la
universalización de la recogida y el
tratamiento de las aguas residuales
tenemos Otro aspecto necesitamos
políticas de vivienda a nivel Federal
Estatal y municipal y de ordenación del
subsuelo a partir del momento en que no
existen estas políticas urbanísticas y
la ocupación y el uso del suelo es
desordenada por cada letrina que se
conecta al sistema de alcantarillado
aparecen otras seis
el agua de esta Bahía se renueva por
completo cada 18 días si la ciudad es
cercanas dejasen de arrojar agua sucia
sin tratamiento al mar la situación
medioambiental mejoraría y mucho Incluso
para la fauna Marina todavía se pueden
ver aquí tortugas y delfines
ambientalistas y biólogos lo tienen
claro esta Bahía todavía está viva y
tiene solución sólo falta voluntad
política hasta aquí el enlace cono Sur
desde la ciudad de Río de Janeiro sobre
el tratamiento de las aguas en Brasil yo
soy Valeria sacona y en la cámara mi
compañero amiguidara hasta la próxima